you
all right under 10 hourly bullet arena
see we get around one chess inc
getting hit with the b3 here because I
have this okay let's go for the space
let's target this guy tough to defend
tough to defend I'm going to just go
straight in for the fork okay take the
rook be a developer I gotta Yates also
threaten you get the Queen's off let's
come back the night might interfere if I
connect rooks
Oh double isolated pawns is not what I
wanted
nope um I don't know I don't want to
take because then maybe I do now have a
my opponent has an easier time getting
at my C pawns okay this is uncomfortable
a little encounter I thought the night
jumping in there would have been the
right thing to do okay I do not mind
night here
and prepared that I think
now let's let's let's go about it in a
different way
Oh
okay there is a file I could work with
should have given the check first that
was silly
Clark
you
in a run here
felt like those last couple moves I
wasn't able to to go fast okay headed
down on the clock there
feel like I should have been able to
convert that out of the opening much
much better
it probably should have captured on f5
when they had the chance their double
isolated ponds is not what I would not
have liked that at all
all right
break the pin
I think Queens see to a little bit
sooner
caused me some problems
take with the F pawn in this case maybe
maybe oh that was a big mess
grab another corner
trip there let's go here before fi hurts
me
it's open up
mmm okay I'll shut it down make up your
mind okay I get rid of that night
put the knight right here
you
some trades get to the zoo this is this
is crashing through this is gonna hurt
got some windmill action okay they went
down feigned
eighty-three in here
Kandee chess master
since second no game against candy chess
master
Scandinavian
space
terally g3
H for a nice prize there
a tempo against the night potentially
castle
take that night later I think I want to
challenge this night
stop the beef or move
player okay - after the B file is opened
I had bishop here as well
being sneaky I win the Queen if they
take twice here I have to take with the
pawn in order to keep this tactic open
on b2 with the Queen and they miss this
Bishop a4 move
that's a free queen
full free
okay
and this one is broken
Queen d2
discoveryland
nearby
hoping for Stanley
can't let that happen
it's me okay yeah there were still ways
off from
having those stalemate resources
let's see 96 in here now
try deform
my rep ie5 to the scandinavian is not
it's not correct
but it's something i
and have some experience with
some little pet set up
I get at age five okay now that's a
piece actually
yes let's take the piece and then here
okay let's not get mated Happy New Year
Happy New Year you just got made it on
f2 I was maybe close to
my mouse lipped bishop there that would
have been right
let's go here prepare to go queenside or
maybe take here hang on
that again check
my nights covering this I'm also on that
light-square control
if the night if it's defended I get to
take on d6
let's take
let's go here I should have been more
aware of this night move let's get him
out of there before he hurts me king c2
all right
and on the rook
light-square control
where is the mate
yeah let's just grab stuff
get the rug huh
okay who feel like I am not playing fast
enough
got eight pyruvic is in there Pahoa Kaz
the next opponent
all right let's go like this I'm going
to allow h4 normally that is stopped
let's stop the night pivot here I
shouldn't castle cuz of this and a pin
Oh Queen
let's go night
Queen on e7 not sure which was about
probably Queen on e7 Queen on c7 if they
try this advance and this becomes a
target they actually took that pawn Wow
why they take that one though all right
opposite sides castling I'm basically
treating this one as put a dent in their
dark squares let's go here control this
break they're probably sacrifice no
sacrifice I win this pawn no rook here I
should have played they should probably
played h4 let's go here let's go here
double up rooks can remove the knight
and then get at this point
I do have a plan not to get made a town
don't get made it
I should just captured
poof so tough poby it's been a while
whoo okay let's go with e4
Sicilian it should be 5 c 3 d 4 in time
I think here I want to play h3 before d4
has to do with this night I don't want
to see it get here let's see
hmm I could jump in the center now Queen
d2 defends everything if she returns or
even wins wins a piece maybe maybe it's
just Queen d2 is solid ok so I want a
dark square Bishop exchange Queen and h6
Knight ng5 made on each seven if I can
there's no fear of Bishop here it's
being cut out so just control the knight
this is a big square for black just
taking it away they're avoiding the dark
scrub issue exchange no they're not so
let's get running with this guy alright
that's a big square here for the Queen
for the night Queen on g5 Knight on f4
and there should be a tactic who Bishop
on d3 as well still shooting for
something over here knight on f4 it's
tremendous Bishop on d3 knight Knight
takes h5 is threatened knight on f6 and
then slither in on the dark squares take
the rook maybe there is even something
better on g6 no time ok the 120 in here
now - is he in a game yes he's in a game
get him Neal
it's in a game against neo let's go at
c5 try and put some
put pressure on the dark squares too
soon oh I just tried to move my bishop
good move um okay let's go back home
[Laughter]
okay okay let's just bring all your
pieces back home
and you get the bishop at the pond
go here
see if they take there there's some
weaknesses maybe I could do some
with that I just dropped upon
Kanchana bullet
I want to take like that
after an exchange now
oh I should
yeah let's take like this and then
tonight
on a secure try and take some steps to
secure my night on c5
oh now this is a forever home for my
night
it in a six I have to this is the only
break I have get one wreck off think one
rock off makes sense
one recover
a bit a rook here and then King up I'm
gonna grab upon
dark square control
it's almost getting mated there
you
ah
Oh down on time oh oh that was a
critical game work my time go
probably at the time I spend going back
home with my pieces setting up for the
next game hmm
okay
let's see
now let's feel ketta
you
I fell I should have had that one it's
bugging me
this is not the way to play
not at all
once again in a similar structure okay
that was helpful
how I was going to approach things if
they didn't make that capture oh the
night could go in here I could have
captured that pun Oh am I missing stuff
am i missing stuff yes I am let's not
miss it again
fufu
bishop
here I guess
awful no oh that would have been
terrible
you
I just take this night ah
prove my king
you
role reversal I cannot move
you
at the resort to the old bag of tricks
the old-time burners watch out for him
28 24 22 under 10 oh this is the guy
that coming
okay gotta go much faster
much faster they move denied
see it oh let's yeah I should have
captured first
yeah is now if I take the route gets to
recapture that's convenient
they're gonna put me in a pin
yepper
my bishops kind of silly on b2
just a defender is all
be threatening to win a piece
let's go all the way back
step up connect rooks my dark square
Bishop continues to not play Bishop is a
little loose on f3
should be pretty cozy though huh am I
missing something no clothes it's real
close missing something night here
no no back off night
this rook
oh there's a night check dummy
try and get the Queens off
I don't promote that
you
trying to get to have six
at the night
no time
okay got them back
28 28 24 I have some fire okay here we
go
it's in 14th me for quick pressure on
the dark squares on the kingside
maybe I want to launch upon and it will
still do it okay yeah you got here and I
think oh my knight on f4 sacrifices
yeah okay this is turning now towards
the queenside
oh don't completely lock up oh that was
helpful
oh no that was a full rook oh boy
that's gonna hurt take what the rook you
know you want to
watch out for the check I got a try for
Perpetual maybe we that's I got a check
here oh boy
around my queen oh oh man I just drop my
queen like we was covered that ah run
for your life run over here oh there's
no more running
what is that you can do Oh Queen g5 I
miss the dirt they're clean was so
hungry
took my rook on aids-free took my queen
on c1 oh I had their queen oh oh that
was a big loss okay this guy again third
time let's try maybe a Kings Indian
attack
with the very early be five so early
that I went in and I lose upon oh man
okay it's not so bad is it
we're gonna find out yeah I do I miss my
e5 pawn it's bad
lights great control maybe maybe we
could get some light square control
careful now Queen g5 can be serious
tried to warn you
rook up seven night here oh there's that
month too is this anything rook drops
back now night here they're gonna see it
all no I got something back it's not
over
still down a lot of material Queen
exchanges keep it keep around for a bit
on be be what that take uhhhh
uncle um maybe I should have captured
the coin there yeah this can hurt me
okay the night is hit I don't know what
that was about
oh boy what pieces aren't hanging here
oh boy Oh
so really hurts it really hurts stop man
it really hurts
Oh wiped out all my tongue just in time
I'm lucky to get away with the draw okay
2:45 oh man oh man
Wow forgot how much fun these
tournaments are Oh find
let's hit him with the F pawn play f4
against Fang
Queen there doesn't win a piece
close
and we're gonna take we're gonna make a
move or not happy with oh man
too much fun
okay I need to get rid of that guy
in here
mates
all I got tricks
one move mates
here here chopping in a push was what I
was hoping for
[Music]
didn't even see that that was a move
whoa
now I'm toast I got feigned I got
feigned ooh Queen h4
I play King f1 Queen Queen h1
that's your tournament winner right
there
ah
one minute ago
wild rook pawn
how will I react oh the double rook pawn
attack look out
light squares
get out of there go ahead take the
exchange I dare you
I dare you telling me
just just throw these one move jabs
that's all
thinking I'm out material I'm not a
material
what's my bishop telling anybody now
don't take their
I could take there now
I got the bishop
see if I can convert
you
oh boy oh boy
kind of silly over here
need to play some defense
I got a different plan let's go here
and then right
I wanna be careful the order
otherwise there's can be some stalemates
there a trough or unreal yeah out here
No okay back to turn who sang taek took
it
bang tank take tit 44 33 30 29 25 out of
podium land
Ahava cook second cover covered coal
third 1:58 now
let's see how the pages 151 158
we're the ones that smack me around
what was that one all right I dropped my
clean my rook okay let's see page two
three four five
pages
okay
you
that's everybody all right
good games
ah that was fun
you